some of the most significant characters
in the wizarding world
are the wondrous creatures
in this film there are exciting new
creatures and all favorites
we've got the niffler who's now called
teddy he remains one of newt's favorite
creatures and also the bane of his life
he's there with pickett
they've sort of sat into their roles as
heroes in these films thank you
there's this extraordinary new creature
called the wyvern which is a little
bird-like two-legged dragon and it has
massive wings
in the harry potter universe the phoenix
is this spirit that comes to
dumbledore's who are in need
fascinating creatures felixes
this phoenix found credence we get the
sense that he cares for credence and is
trying to protect him
but these new creatures
are not always our friends we've got
these amazing creatures
which are called manticores now i'm
excited for the world to see manticores
they're these sweet little crab-like
things that are obviously in no way
shape or form sweet
after the harry potter films i was
desperate to make a film where we could
just explore beautiful mysterious
magical creatures
i couldn't be more excited to join them
on their adventure
[Music]
[Music]
you